c'est pour discuter notamment de la
situation au sahel que la ministre des
armées florence paris et à washington
aujourd'hui son entourage assure que le
soutien des états unis pour aider la
france à accompagner les pays de la
région est essentielle
on trouve sur place à washington notre
correspondante on abonnés thomas bonjour
florence parle il vient tout juste de
s'exprimer oui elle a donc été interrogé
sur cette situation au sahel parce
qu'évidemment il ya une sorte de
coïncidence une concomitance entre le
retrait français au sahel et le retrait
américain en afghanistan alors florence
parly a quand même tenu à préciser que
la france ne se retirait pas du sel on
ne quitte pas le sel on va continuer à
combattre le terrorisme c'est ce qu'elle
a expliqué en affirmant qu'il y aurait
encore entre 2500 et 3000 soldats
français avec une nouvelle stratégie
donc et que cette transformation ne veut
pas donc nous ont pas dire qu'il y aura
un désengagement l'idée maintenant pour
la france selon la ministre des armées
ce sera plutôt de viser les leaders
terroristes et d'ailleurs elle a
rencontré ce matin son homologue
américain lloyd austin le secrétaire
d'état américain à la défense et ils ont
noué un partenariat pour renforcer
justement la coopération entre les
forces spéciales françaises et
américaines
un partenariat qui pourra justement être
mis en place mis en exécution dans la
région du sahel mais plus généralement
donc cette visite de florence parly
c'était sa première visite depuis
l'élection de joe biden et c'était une
forme de concrétisation du rapprochement
qui a été amorcé par le président
américain lors de son voyage en europe
écoutez par exemple les tout premiers
mots de florence parly c'était lors de
son discours d'introduction
depuis ma dernière visite il y a un an
de l'eau a coulé sous les ponts et j'ai
le sentiment que beaucoup de problèmes
ont été réglés avec ce changement
j'aimerais commencer avec certains faits
essentiels
nous accueillons avec bonheur
l'administration de biden et sa forte
volonté de revenir dans la discussion
on comprend en filigrane qui les fait
question évocation de donald trump
évidemment et donc que cette nouvelle
administration est une bonne nouvelle en
tout cas c'est ce qu'annonce florence
parly qui dit que la france n'a jamais
eu l'intention de tourner le dos aux
etats unis elle est revenue assez
longuement sur cette coopération sur le
plus vieil allié des états unis la
france donc avec donc aussi les propos
d' emmanuel macron en octobre 2019 quand
il avait 10 rappelez-vous que l'otan
était en état de mort cérébrale elle a
dit que c'était une sorte de tempête
dans un verre d'eau mais que cela avait
permis quand même de mener une réflexion
sur la coopération et sur la cour et de
la coopération a mené entre la france
l'europe plus généralement et les états
unis elle a elle même déclarée
l'amérique est de retour elle a donc
repris texto est la formule de joe biden
américaine de retour at-elle déclaré au
travail
voilà les mots de florence parly ici à
washington merci beaucoup thomas bonnin